we are honoring extraordinary moms all
week long
and one of them is clarissa joy
she had it all two degrees a successful
career
and a family and then all that changed
when she got divorced and
then she quickly turned that fear into
confidence and
launched this very successful nonprofit
called
rise up single moms and it supports
countless single moms
all over the country and clarissa is
here now to talk about it with us
welcome clarissa joy
hi true wow i can't believe i'm here
i was so excited to talk to you
i'm a single mom so i was very
interested in your story what compelled
you
to help other women not feel alone
it started with a simple facebook post
it was the end of 2016
and i was looking back over the year and
i was so excited that i was
okay right as a single mom after going
through so much
you know darkness and i just simply
wanted to share that with other moms
and then the responses just poured in of
other moms thanking me for the post and
i was like wow
where did this come from um and then
fast forward in 2017
uh we started the non-profit
organization to rise up single mom
is it true that you kept your divorce a
secret from
people in the beginning absolutely i
actually even wore my wedding ring a
year after the divorce
simply because i didn't want to feel
like a failure
and i didn't want people to think that i
was a failure and you know well how good
can she be in other areas if now her
marriage has failed absolutely that's it
if you can't figure out marriage then
they probably can't figure out anything
else absolutely
that's what i was thinking that's why i
didn't want to share it
that is one of the most honest poignant
ways i've gotten to put how divorce
feels with another woman
it's like you are convinced that others
will look at you as if it has a
trickle-down
effect to everything absolutely it's
this paranoia is going on in your head
and despite whether others think that
way or not
it's your reality it's how you're
feeling inside so like
what do you say to other mothers
watching right now who are raising their
kids
on their own and feeling any of the
things we have mentioned
i would say to other moms it's okay
there are others that feel
exactly as you do and just as i was
there
you also can come from that place you
will be okay
um this is only a season you'll get
through it go
clarissa where were you when i first got
divorced i'm serious
thank goodness that you have been such
an inspiration to so many moms
and uh today um our entire virtual
audience
is filled with single moms so hello
ladies
i know how cool is that there's actually
someone here who has a special message
for you
tanya are you there
hi drew hi clarissa
hi tanya thank you for joining us today
good how are you listen
i'm so excited to be here really just
thrilled i wanted to say
to clarissa thank you so much for
uh founding rise up single mom the first
time that i actually met
with the organization it was a moms go
back to school event
and i remember clarissa clearly saying
begin
with the end in mind and it always stuck
with me
and i'm here today to say that we
registered for school that day i
registered for
my master's degree at the university of
memphis i have completed
all of the classes except for one class
that starts
in july and i just want to say thank you
clarissa
for the catalyst that helped me through
those tiny steps
to get to my success so thank you again
i'm so thankful and grateful for this
organization
all the amazing moms in our audience we
want to celebrate you by giving you
each 100 gift certificate to urban stem
flowers
a company that i really really really
love
and um clarissa you're just so inspiring
and
we at the show would love to just give
five thousand dollars towards rise up
single mom
and support your mission
it's hard to put into words what you're
doing but
you do wonder if people think you're
incapable of handling other parts of
your life if you couldn't handle this
and i just think what you're doing is
amazing
and very necessary wow i just can't say
thank you enough this is so truly
amazing
well i thank you to our vff's for
coming and showing up for clarissa
tanya thank you so much and go to our
website to learn more about
rise up single mom an organization
that i cannot advocate support
and shine a light on moore thank you
clarissa joy
so much